i don't know if you saw on my instagram
ilaria baldwin returning to instagram
after questions about her true heritage
rocked the internet there's been some
questions
about where i'm born i'm born in boston
i spent some of my childhood in boston
some of my childhood in spain
in this new post ellaria shares that she
spent the last month
listening reflecting and asking herself
how she can learn and grow
the yoga expert writes in part quote my
parents raised my brother and me with
two cultures
american and spanish and i feel a true
sense of belonging to both
the way i've spoken about myself and my
deep connection to two cultures could
have been better explained
i should have been more clear and i'm
sorry ellaria goes on to explain that
she's proud of the way she was raised
and how she's now raising
her kids to have the same love and
respect for both cultures
being vulnerable and pushing ourselves
to learn and grow
is what we've built our community on and
i hope to get back to the supportive and
kind environment we've built together
as a reminder in december confusion
swirled online about whether ellaria was
born in spain
or boston my wife is from spain in 2013
alex said she was from spain but in 2012
ellaria tweeted she was born
in boston the questions about her roots
grew rampant in late 2020.
and in january 2021 a source told et
that elaria and her family were
upset that her background was being
questioned the source added that alec
always knew ellaria was from boston i'm
born in boston
it was literally the first thing that i
told my husband last year the couple
welcomed their fifth child together
after suffering two miscarriages i'm
doing as
as best as you can but no i'm much
better than i was last week and
you know coming out and talking about it
and sharing i think has been very
healing for me
i have a million children so it's not
very glamorous but yeah is that the
[Music]
truth